اكثر من شهر على الحرب في السودان حيث
النزاع بين الجيش بقياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان والدعم السريع لقياده حم ثمانيه
هدى انسانيه توصل اليها الطرفان لكنها
خلقت كل منها بنسب متفاوته والحصيله من كل
هذا
865 قتيلا من المدنيين واكثر من ثلاثه
الاف جريح رغم ان الارقام مرتفعه لكن من
المحتمل ان تكون الارقام الحقيقيه اعلى من
ذلك بكثير فاغلب الضحايا بطبيعه الحال
سقطوا في نقطه الصراع المركزي الخرطوم
الوضع في السودان معقد للغايه ويبدو عصيا
عن الحل بحسب الكثيرين ومن بينهم جوزيف
بوريل مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي برايه لا توجد اراده لدى طرفي
الصراع في حل سياسي لكن دعونا نلقي نظره
على خريطه المعارك بعد اكثر من شهر على
النزاع في ولايه الخرطوم مركز المعارك
الرئيسى السيطره منقسمه بين الطرفين في
مدن ولايه الولايه الثلاث الخرطوم بحري
والخرطوم العاصمه وانظر من في مدينه
الخرطوم بحريه يسطر الدعم السريع على
غالبيه اجزاء المدينه حيث تنتشر في منطقه
الخرطوم بحري وجنوب الخرطوم في مدينه
الخرطوم العاصمه مازال صراع السيطره على
مطار الخرطوم الدولي الدائرا بين الطرفين
يسيطر الجيش على الجزء الاكبر من القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه بينما تتواجد قوات
الدعم السريع في جزء من القياده العامه
اما في ام درمان يسيطر الجيش السوداني على
اغلب مناطق المدينه بينما تسيطر قوات
الدعم السريع على مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون
والذي تعرض محيطه لقصف جويا قوي قبل دخول
الهدنه حيز التنفيذ في ظل سعي الجيش
للسيطره عليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات